foreign
guys I'm on a mission I'm busting Tommy
out of school how could I possibly be
expected to handle School in a day like
this
um Bueller
Bueller
Tommy's day off we got ticket in there
oh that sounds good
you haven't lived unless you've eaten
Peruvian rotisserie chicken
foreign
over this way
[Applause]
we are on an abandoned highway more than
80 years ago this thing was built as a
modern engineering Marvel and in the 60s
it was replaced by a larger more
efficient Highway and this became
abandoned so me and Tom are going to
explore this abandoned Turnpike and a
couple potentially haunted tunnels and
we're gonna do a little bit of a camping
trip you excited Tom yeah
is this crazy we're just riding down the
highway
well the first thing we noticed is that
there is a healthy amount of graffiti on
this road Tom Tommy's learning some new
words
yeah Tom if you see a car coming let me
know okay
somebody lost their blankie I'm
surprised how good shape this Road's in
look up ahead there's a tunnel and it
might even be haunted
me out
okay that's creepy okay I'm nervous
well let's let's stop here Tom
this is crazy you wanna come exploring
here
oh wow
all right all right should we go and
explore this creepy haunted tunnel
look at this
whoa
this place is trash
oh
look at this
uh yeah that doesn't look safe anymore
yeah that looks like a death trap right
there and why did someone Drive
look at this
oh yeah like the storm drain sewer in
there
the Wolves falling apart
is it cold yeah that looks like coal
right there in the old days a lot of
places were heated with coal they would
stockpile a coal and then shovel it in
and
look at that I think that's coal
I was like cold dust oh yep there is
somebody's underwear right there
I think Jacob must be in here
huh you'll float too that sounds fun
the trailer for Success
I'm shaking that old rusted staircase we
saw goes up to those offices up there at
the top I ain't risking my neck to go up
there
there's the gutters down there
[Music]
oh look at this that's the side of the
mountain right there
oh wow this is cool
all right you want to ride the tunnel
yep
turn your light on
this tunnel is Pitch Black and the only
sound is water dripping on garbage
Tommy is this tunnel scary yeah
[Music]
yeah there is a lot of graffiti here
we literally cannot see the light at the
end of the tunnel it is dark
this is a little scary isn't it yes
ah
dad cut that out
there's like a hollow compartment above
the tunnel you can see where the lights
used to be
wow yeah there's like a whole nother
tunnel above the tunnel Tommy is this
the creepiest bike ride you've ever done
yeah what is that
you can see these holes where they used
to be lights or something they're all
smashed why do people keep spray
painting pictures of male anatomy I'm
like that's
so strange
[Music]
I'm not reading the words
that is a good zombie picture I think I
could see somebody up ahead
those might be the dead eyes of Haunting
ghosts
oh they don't look Undead at all how you
doing
oh we're starting to go downhill
we're getting some speed
oh Tom I think I can see the light at
the end of the tunnel I figured out why
we couldn't see the light at the end of
the tunnel when we started there's a
hill inside this tunnel and so you have
to get in the middle of the tunnel on
the top of the hill to be able to see
the light on both ends of the tunnel at
the same time
but the good news is it's downhill now
oh we made it it's not warmer out here
oh yeah the staircase in here is
shot to pieces
there you go it goes up quite a ways up
there it looks like it's all rotted out
too
another one hey Tom do you want to climb
down to the sewers
what
climb down the city oh there's a lot of
water down there looks like this is
where they keep their coal over here
all right Tom you want to keep exploring
great or that that is that took some
Talent that's some crazy sauce right
there but it's impressive artwork
well that was a lot cooler than I was
expecting it was a big tunnel oh
something's not right
oh I got a flat
there's so much broken glass and beer
bottles down there I might have run over
something
uh
well a couple things have gone wrong
with this trip first the tire obviously
but also the camping originally I'd
planned on camping here and camping in
the tunnels overnight which I thought
would be really cool and spooky and I
had been told that that was okay but
when we got here there was some pretty
clear signs that said we were not
allowed to be here after dark and no
camping allowed
well I promised Tommy a special Father
and Son trip and I took him out of
school so we're in way too deep to turn
back now I gotta think of a plan B why
plan C here it is plan C can't possibly
fail
oh look at this
yeah these are wild grapes wild grapes
just growing right there I'm not gonna
eat them though because there's an
invasive species in Virginia that looks
similar to Wild Grape so I'm not 100
sure
[Music]
all right Tom you got those snacks handy
right here right here good we might need
to drowned our sorrows in sugar and fat
that's very Zinger oh geez that looks
good
okay we're just leaving our second Hotel
here in Gettysburg and everyone is
booked up we can't find a room
Tom I'm hungry you just want to go find
a restaurant and we'll figure out the
hotel later yeah yeah all right let's do
it
so we're doing some Mexican food
because when you go to Gettysburg
Pennsylvania you gotta eat Mexican
food
your first Pennsylvania tacos
the car and I know it's the front tire
of my bike is flat check this out
look at this
see this right here crazy wrinkled and
melted and stuff and the exhaust pipe
heated and melted my tire dang it
Hal popped both tires on my bike this
trip is cursed yes me and Tom tied
calling a couple different hotels here
in Gettysburg and the cheapest one we
found was 300 a night it's insane so
we're gonna drive about 40 minutes away
see if we can go camping
we're here at cadora State Park in
Pennsylvania and we found a place it's
36 bucks a night for a tent spot but I'm
grateful to have it
foreign
all right
is that comfy enough for you
hopefully our 10 doesn't catch fire in
the night or we get eaten by a bear or
something because this this trip is
cursed yes
I'm gonna see you guys in the morning
well good morning me and Tom are just
hanging out here in bed and we're
watching Operation Petticoat on my phone
you enjoying the movie yeah old Cary
Graham movie it's pretty good
it's always weird waking up in a place
you've only seen in the Darkness
oh
so Tom would you rather eat some camping
meals or go out to breakfast breakfast
well we saved ourselves about three
hundred dollars by camping here instead
of getting a hotel so you know that pays
for a tent in one night
there you go there's the lake
well all right guys this is Codorus Lake
and we were staying at cadora State Park
campground so very little pretty little
Reservoir all right Tom you want to go
get some breakfast
do it
oh my goodness
that is a waffle split it's a banana
split with a waffle vanilla ice cream
whipped cream strawberries bananas
chocolate syrup on a waffle oh that was
good like your French toast home yeah
have you had a good time yep even though
this trip has gone a little bit weird
yeah
there she is oh she looks so clean and
beautiful
look at that
let's get this thing home
so this little fishing boat I've had for
almost 10 years now it's just been a
great boat it's a mini pontoon it's 13
feet long by seven feet wide which is
great because I can tow it quite easily
with this little SUV of ours and uh I
bought it from the guys up here at FNS
Yamaha in Pennsylvania and I have them
service it all the time and it's just
been great all right guys well me and
Tommy just got pulled over by the police
Tommy says that the officer thinks we're
sus that's slang for suspicious
apparently yeah that's how we help me
stop this this really is a cursed trip
isn't this Tommy yeah yes but it's a fun
curse trap
yeah fun being
it's fun being cursed the officer just
thought we might have been stealing
stuff yeah
I have that look about me
hey baby
already switched Tommy out for Nathan
here at the house and uh we're gonna go
to a bike shop Nathan wants a bike and
we got a bunch of bikes to fix
everything like that because if I do it
like this
yeah you want you want to try the seat
up a little bit more thank you see you
later so Nathan do you like your new
bike yes yeah you got a fancy bike
that's a big boy bike
[Music]
what do you think Jake is that cool
ER yeah oh babe I thought you're home oh
glad to be home it didn't quite work out
the way I wanted but it's nice to be
with you well guys this video is a
little bit light so I'm gonna do
something I don't normally do which is
answer some of your questions do a
little bit of vlogging and the number
one question I hear from people is about
my weight loss so back in 2021 I dropped
65 pounds in four months
um I had people asking me if I had
cancer or stomach ulcers it was like
when you Googled my name it was the
number one autofill like what's up with
Luke's weight loss so basically I just
came to my attention that I was
technically obese I am short
of that and so I want to get healthier
and drop the weight and so I just
starved myself for four months I didn't
do any exercise I just cut my food
intake in half
oh yes I'm rumbly in my tumbly I started
dieting right after we rented the tank
in Texas and most of it happened while
we were doing the longest road trip in
the United States where we drove from
Key West Florida to Dead Horse Alaska
that took 48 days so almost half of my
dieting was on the road pretty much all
just portion control just being hungry
so the key to my diet be hungry so right
after that road trip I'd hit my weight
loss goal and I'm happy with it and I've
been maintaining it for about a year
just by you know not eating too much
another question I get all the time is
where are we living or where are we
moving to or what our plans in that
regard are for the future and I just
don't address those questions speak for
safety reasons we have almost two and a
half million fans on this channel alone
uh that we've gotten almost three
quarters of a billion views and while
most the people who watch our videos are
just awesome people there are a few
people who are not well or are not safe
or just don't understand boundaries and
to protect my family and because of
incidences that have happened in the
past we I just don't like to advertise
where we're going to be in the future
and by the time you see these videos
it's usually been several weeks if not
months so often when you see us in
England or Alaska or Iceland or wherever
by the time you see the video we were
long gone and I do that deliberately for
safety reasons but what I can tell you
is that we travel a lot and we will
continue to be traveling a lot and
you're going to see us all over this
country and on a lot of other countries
as well it's a lot of fun trips a lot of
fun videos coming in the future another
question I get all the time is am I
still practicing law or am I doing
YouTube full time and the answer is I'm
doing YouTube full time and I have been
since a little bit before covid and
while it's really nice to spend more
time with the family and things like
that I get to see my kids while I work I
work a lot more hours doing YouTube than
I do Privacy Law
uh it's it's been interesting um the
other questions they get a lot is people
asking where we can buy uh outdoor boys
merchandise or question about outdoor
boys merchandise like t-shirts and stuff
and I put a link in the video
description of every video to our
merchandise store and basically it's
this third party seller where we upload
our designs and they take care of
everything like I literally don't get
any free merchandise I have to pay full
price for my own stuff you know and I
get a very small portion of the sale
um so it's one of those things I don't
push because I don't like to film my
videos for all of advertising and
frankly the only reason why I do offer
merchandise is because so many people
have asked me for it that Becca finally
uploaded it and took care of it so that
you know you guys would have something
so it's great if that's something you
want to have but you know don't do it
for me do it if it's something you want
another question I get a lot is about
Becca's paintings a lot of people have
noticed it back as a painter she does
watercolor and oils and it's a fun thing
she does and I've had people ask can you
buy her paintings and Becca actually did
upload a bunch of her paintings and you
can buy prints of her paintings and I'll
put a link to that in the video
description below so another question I
get is about my sister Melanie uh she
comes with us on a lot of trips and is
featured in a lot of our videos and
she's a professional novelist and she
publishes books I think she's published
like 15 books or something like that
and she writes romance novels like uh
Victorian era and Regency Era romance
actually pretty good books if you're
into that and
um her pen name is M.A Nichols and I'll
put a link to that below because a lot
of people ask me where they can get her
books I also get a lot of questions
about the gear I use in particular
videos and I don't spend a lot of time
talking about it because I don't do
sponsorships and I don't want to turn my
videos into commercials and any rate if
you want to know more about the gear I
used often check our Facebook page
um that sort of informational often post
on our Facebook page instead of the
YouTube channel or if you want to ask
questions you can ask them on the
Facebook page because there's actually
comments on the Facebook page there's no
comments on our YouTube channel another
question I get all the time is why there
are no comments on my YouTube videos and
the short answer is that YouTube
disabled the comment feature on my
channel a number of years ago some sick
individuals were leaving very
inappropriate comments on channels and
videos that feature children and so
YouTube disabled comments on all videos
and all channels that feature children
and my channel was affected by this
policy however I realized that this was
a big blessing in disguise first off I
was spending almost an hour a day
admitting and monitoring the comments on
my YouTube videos it's just something
that had to be done because of the
amount of spam and inappropriate
comments that people would leave so
suddenly I had an extra hour a day to
worry about making better videos and not
dealing with comments the other thing I
realized was that only point three
percent of the people who watch my
videos were leaving comments so turning
off comments was really only affecting a
very small percentage of my audience and
since comments are disabled I just worry
a lot less about what people think or
what people are going to say and I just
focus on making better videos and my
life has been a lot less stressful well
for those dedicated few who watch this
video at the end I hope this answered
some of your more pressing questions and
if you like this sort of v-log q a check
out some of our older videos I used to
do this a lot and all of our videos that
we've made are still up on our YouTube
channel there's over 400 videos on this
channel and almost 400 videos on my
other YouTube channel the catfish and
carp YouTube channel so I have something
like eight nine years and over 800
videos up online and still all of them
are fully available so check that out
and we put out new videos every Saturday
morning so don't forget to click
subscribe and I'll see you guys next
Saturday morning all right see you then
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button and you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]